ELVIS WITH THOSE NICE BABY BLUE
PAPA MEAN,HERE BY STANLEY,
WINNIPEG KEEP IT IN COLUMBUS
TERRITORY.
SWEPT TOWOW DEFENSIVE ZONE PLAYE
GOES  ON THE LEFT WING,
WINNIPEG WILL CHIP IT DUBOIS.
AND THE PUCK D
HIGH.
BACKHANDED AND
SHOVELED OFF BY
>> Jody: WELL, DICEY PLAY THERE
AND SMART PLAY BY KYLE CONNOR,
PLAY, 10 FOR 49.
LED BY MORRISSEY F F ELVIS, BUT
THERE ON THE DOORSTEP, ANOTHER
ATTEMPT, THIS T T 21 BEFOREPUCK!
IN FRONT CLEARING PASS OFF
THE SKATE OF BOONEVORACEK, LEFT
CENTER, HE HAS SILLINGER AND
CH YEARS AND
THIS IS ONE OF THE START.
TH ARE.
>> Jody: NO ONE UNDERTHE JETS HY
WHEELER TRYING TO FIND D  THROU
BUT HELLEBUYCK RIGHT THERE.
>> Jody: TWICE TO START TO WALK
OUT OF THE CORNER COMES KYLE
CONNOR.
KYLE CONNOR FIGHTS THROUGH THE
CHECK THERE OF JAKE BEAN.CK,
THERE'S DUBOIS WITH A LITTLE
PLAY
WE'LL SEE HOW THIS ONE SETS UP
FOR THIS TEAM THAT'S AT
KIND OF A FEELING
AND DUBOIS HEARS FROM THE CROWD
AS HE RACED UP I COULDN'T GOEST
THE NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE, HOW
BUT WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT IT
JETS WHO, TO ME THE BLUE JACKETS
LOOK
WILL COME THERE AHEAD OF
SCHEIFELE.
DUMPS IT BACK BELOW THE PLAYER .
>> Jody: THAT'S WHEELER.
>> Jeff: ATTEMPTPLAY, HE'S
A THREAT AND MAKES EVERYONE A
LITTLE BUT
NOTIDE AND OPENS UP
HERE IN
THAT OFFENSIVE ZONE AND THIS
TIME ON THERE, VERY
CALMLY PLAYED AND HELD BY ELVIS
MERZLIOOD SHOVE
THERE ON HIS BUDDY THERE  THE W.
DeMELO KEEP IT IN.
ELVIS, WHO WANTS TO SCORE A E
GETS A NICE